Il metodo di diagonalizzazione quantistica basata su campioni, o SQD in breve, è un algoritmo ibrido quantistico-classico come la
diagonalizzazione quantistica di Krylov, KQD, come VQE e molti altri. Nell'usare tali algoritmi ibridi,
può essere utile pensare a dove ciascun algoritmo sfrutta il computing quantistico e quello classico. Ricorda che VQE crea stati su un
circuit quantistico usando parametri ottimizzati classicamente. In quel caso, lo stato stesso è su un computer quantistico. Anche se
ottenere lo stato target è un processo che combina sia il computing classico che quello quantistico.
Il valore di aspettazione dell'operatore viene calcolato usando misurazioni quantistiche.
Ma è necessaria anche una certa combinazione classica dei termini.
Al contrario, SQD usa un computer quantistico per generare un sottospazio utile su cui proiettare l'Hamiltoniano o un altro operatore.
L'Hamiltoniano viene poi diagonalizzato interamente in modo classico per trovare lo stato target. Supponiamo di avere un
problema di interesse scientifico o industriale che può essere formulato come un problema di risolutore di autovalori su una matrice di n righe e
n colonne. Supponiamo inoltre che n sia abbastanza grande da rendere la diagonalizzazione classica esatta non un'opzione. Sarebbe
chiaramente vantaggioso ridurre le dimensioni della nostra matrice preservando tutte le caratteristiche rilevanti dello stato fondamentale. Questo è, in effetti,
l'obiettivo di molti approcci approssimati al risolutore di autovalori, inclusi i metodi classici di Krylov. Supponiamo di sapere abbastanza del nostro problema da fare
un'ipotesi ragionevolmente buona sulla forma dello stato fondamentale, ma non abbastanza da risolvere il problema direttamente. In quel
caso, potremmo fare molte misurazioni di una buona approssimazione dello stato fondamentale target. I risultati di queste
misurazioni ci forniscono un sottospazio di stati della base computazionale che contiene tutte le componenti rilevanti del nostro
stato fondamentale. Proiettare su quel sottospazio produrrebbe una matrice più piccola che contiene ancora i gradi di
libertà rilevanti. Il flusso di lavoro per questo è il seguente. Si inizia scegliendo un buon
ansatz. Più precisamente, scegli un ansatz il cui supporto coincida con quello dello stato target. Discuteremo esattamente cosa
significa. Successivamente, misura lo stato nella base computazionale come si fa con il sampler primitive.
Poi, usa i risultati del campionamento per definire un sottospazio che contenga lo stato fondamentale.
Poi, proietta la tua matrice su quel sottospazio. Infine, diagonalizza classicamente la matrice proiettata più piccola.
Analizziamo ciascuno di questi passi, prestando particolare attenzione alla definizione del sottospazio.
In tutto il quantum computing, scegliere un buon ansatz è sempre fondamentale. Nel caso di SQD, la tua scelta di ansatz
determinerà quali stati della base computazionale possono essere misurati nel campionamento.
Il vero stato fondamentale può essere espresso come sovrapposizione di un sottoinsieme di stati della base computazionale. Quel sottoinsieme
è chiamato supporto dello stato fondamentale. Per ottenere una buona stima dello stato fondamentale e della sua energia, il tuo ansatz
deve avere una proiezione non nulla sugli stati della base computazionale nel supporto dello stato fondamentale.
Questo diagramma rappresenta lo spazio generato da tutti i possibili stati sul numero di qubit utilizzati. Vogliamo un
ansatz il cui supporto contenga il supporto del vero stato fondamentale.
Considera un sistema di esempio molto piccolo con uno stato fondamentale pari a 8 volte
lo stato 1 0 0 più 6 volte lo stato 001.
Questo ha un supporto formato da quei due vettori 1 0 0 e 0 0 1. Diciamo che l'ansatz è della forma: ansatz 1 è A volte
lo stato 1 0 0 più B volte lo stato 0 1 0 più C volte lo stato 0 0 1. In modo che il suo
supporto sia l'insieme dei tre vettori 1 0 0, 0 1 0 e 0 0 1, un sovrainsieme del
supporto dello stato fondamentale. Questo è un buon ansatz.
Ora immagina di aver invece scelto un ansatz della forma: ansatz 2 è a volte
lo stato 1 1 0 più b volte lo stato 0 1 1.
Questo ha un supporto formato da quei due vettori 1 1 0 e 0 1 1, che non ha sovrapposizione con il supporto dello stato
fondamentale. Questo è un cattivo ansatz.
Nota che non è necessariamente richiesto che l'ansatz sia una buona approssimazione dello stato fondamentale. L'ansatz potrebbe
avere un supporto molto più grande oppure i coefficienti potrebbero essere molto diversi sull'ansatz e sul vero stato fondamentale e funzionare ugualmente bene.
A questo punto, abbiamo usato un ansatz ben motivato per far adottare al computer quantistico uno stato simile al nostro
stato target. Mostrato qui è l'ansatz unitario accoppiato Jastrow, o UCJ, molto utile in chimica quantistica.
Vogliamo ora misurare lo stato del sistema ottenendo stringhe di bit che descrivono lo stato collassato di ciascun
qubit. Ricorda che la stima dell'Hamiltoniano come in VQE richiede molte misurazioni quantistiche. Questo è in parte per
ridurre l'incertezza e in parte a causa del numero di gruppi di operatori di Pauli commutanti che compongono l'Hamiltoniano.
Nei metodi di campionamento, hai ancora bisogno di molte misurazioni, ma le ragioni sono diverse. Ora abbiamo bisogno di molte misurazioni per campionare efficacemente i
molti stati della base computazionale coinvolti in stati quantistici altamente entangled. In SQD, le stringhe di bit campionate corrispondono
a configurazioni del sistema simulato. Se il sistema studiato è soggetto a vincoli assoluti come
leggi di conservazione in fisica o chimica, allora la maggior parte degli stati misurati sarà valida. Ma alcune stringhe di bit campionate
corrispondono a configurazioni non valide o non fisiche a causa di rumore ed errori. Un processo chiamato
configuration recovery mira a raffinare questi campioni rumorosi in un insieme di configurazioni più accurate.
Questo processo prevede la generazione di nuove configurazioni invertendo probabilisticamente singoli bit in base a
occupanze orbitali medie e numeri di particelle noti.
Le configurazioni raffinate vengono poi usate per generare sottospazi per la proiezione e diagonalizzazione dell'Hamiltoniano,
migliorando iterativamente la fedeltà della rappresentazione dello stato quantistico.
Vediamo un esempio banalmente piccolo di configuration recovery per capirne il significato. Supponiamo di misurare un
sistema quantistico con quattro qubit che rappresentano quattro orbitali molecolari e di ottenere le seguenti stringhe di bit dal
processore quantistico. Ogni stringa di bit rappresenta l'occupanza di un orbitale. Uno per
occupato, zero per non occupato. Qiskit usa una notazione in cui il qubit meno significativo è sul lato destro.
WEBVTT
Ad esempio, 1 0 1 0 indica che gli orbitali 1 e 3 sono occupati. Queste
misurazioni sono state scelte solo per ragioni pedagogiche. Le occupanze risultanti potrebbero non corrispondere a un sistema fisico. In contesti fisici, è
spesso il caso che il sistema abbia un numero totale di particelle noto. Possono esserci anche altre leggi di conservazione che
puoi sfruttare per determinare la fisicità di uno stato misurato. Per restare concreti, supponiamo che il nostro sistema sia
noto per avere un numero totale di particelle n = 2. Questo ci dice il numero totale di uni che dovrebbero comparire nella nostra etichetta di stato,
il che si chiama vincolo di peso di Hamming.
Tuttavia, alcune configurazioni misurate violano questo vincolo. Lo stato 1 0 1 0 è fisicamente valido. Ma lo stato 1 1
1 0 ha troppe particelle e lo stato di tutti zeri ne ha troppo poche. Zero
di fatto. Queste violazioni possono essere dovute a rumore nel sistema o errori nella misurazione. Abbiamo bisogno di un modo per tornare
a configurazioni che abbiano senso fisico, almeno in modo approssimativo.
Questo si chiama configuration recovery.
Per correggere i nostri campioni rumorosi, invertiamo probabilisticamente i bit nelle configurazioni non valide in base all'occupanza orbitale media
calcolata sulle configurazioni valide.
Le occupanze orbitali sono i valori di aspettazione dell'operatore numero che agisce su ciascun orbitale. Questo viene stimato e
raffinato in modo autoconsistente usando gli stati prodotti da SQD. Guarda l'orbitale 2 per esempio. In due delle
quattro configurazioni valide, l'orbitale 2 era occupato. Questo ci dà un'occupanza attesa di 0,5.
Facciamo lo stesso per gli altri tre orbitali. Ora torniamo a una configurazione non valida 1 1 0. Possiamo invertire uno dei
bit da 1 a zero per generare una configurazione valida. Ma quale dobbiamo invertire? Un modo per decidere è
attraverso lo scarto dell'occupanza di ciascun orbitale rispetto alle medie appena calcolate.
Qui vediamo che la differenza più grande è nell'occupazione dell'orbitale uno. Quindi potremmo aspettarci che il bit uno debba essere
invertito da uno a zero. Certo, l'orbitale 2 non è molto indietro. Ed è sempre possibile, per quanto improbabile, che
questo stato misurato sia il risultato di errori multipli sullo stesso stato.
Scegliere solo lo scarto maggiore dalla media per tutti gli stati non validi non è ottimale. Invece, i bit vengono invertiti
probabilisticamente con la probabilità che è una funzione delle differenze mostrate qui. Supponiamo che in questo
caso cambiamo il bit che differisce di più dall'occupazione media. Quindi 1 1 0 diventa 1 0 0. Faremmo lo stesso
processo per l'altra scelta non valida. Diciamo che in questo caso finiamo per invertire i bit uno e tre.
Dopo questo processo di correzione, abbiamo un nuovo insieme di configurazioni che potrebbero avere questo aspetto.
Usando questo insieme raffinato, possiamo aggiornare l'occupanza orbitale media per migliorare la fedeltà. Nel nostro caso, le nuove
occupanze sono queste.
Questo processo di recupero iterativo garantisce che le misurazioni rumorose vengano filtrate in configurazioni fisicamente significative,
migliorando l'accuratezza delle approssimazioni degli autostati in SQD. Il componente aggiuntivo Qiskit di SQD ha alcuni strumenti che
saranno fondamentali in questo processo. Se abbiamo fatto un buon lavoro campionando gli stati nel supporto del vero stato fondamentale
del sistema, dovremmo essere in grado di guardare solo le parti dell'Hamiltoniano che agiscono su questo sottospazio
e ottenere comunque un buon stato fondamentale e la sua energia. Nel nostro banalmente piccolo esempio a 4 qubit, ci sono inizialmente 2 alla 4, cioè 16,
possibili stati del sistema. Usando una combinazione di campionamento e configuration recovery, riduciamo questo
a tre stati nel nostro sottospazio di interesse. Tre stati che speriamo costituiscano il supporto del vero stato fondamentale.
Ora proiettiamo il nostro Hamiltoniano completo su quel sottospazio. Ossia, creiamo una matrice M da una colonna di vettori del nostro
sottospazio campionato recuperato e una analoga M dagger dalle righe, e moltiplichiamo M dagger H M
pittoricamente. Questo significa prendere gli elementi di matrice nelle righe e colonne corrispondenti agli stati nel nostro
sottospazio campionato recuperato. Le righe e colonne evidenziate sono quelle corrispondenti al nostro sottospazio. E le
caselle evidenziate più scure in cui si sovrappongono sono gli elementi che conserviamo per la nostra nuova matrice proiettata.
Ora che abbiamo selezionato il sottospazio di interesse, possiamo diagonalizzare questa matrice su un computer classico
usando un risolutore standard. Se il vero stato fondamentale è composto interamente da stati nel nostro sottospazio, questa
diagonalizzazione dovrebbe restituire il corretto stato fondamentale e la corretta energia. Se abbiamo solo la maggior parte del supporto dello stato fondamentale,
potremmo avvicinarci. Una volta ottenuto lo stato fondamentale per questo Hamiltoniano proiettato, abbiamo uno stato molto
utile da cui calcolare l'occupanza media di ciascun orbitale.
In precedenza, le nostre occupanze erano calcolate dagli stati che avevamo campionato usando un ansatz che speravamo ci aiutasse
ad avvicinarci al nostro stato fondamentale. Ma non c'era garanzia che l'occupanza media di ciascun orbitale da quel campionamento corrispondesse all'occupanza
nello stato a energia più bassa. Facciamo un passo indietro. Avevamo un campionamento di stati computazionali. Abbiamo usato la configuration recovery
per correggere quelli fisicamente non validi. Poi abbiamo calcolato l'occupanza orbitale media usando tutti. Lo
stato fondamentale potrebbe includerne solo alcuni. Lo stato fondamentale di questo Hamiltoniano proiettato potrebbe non essere il vero stato fondamentale
del nostro sistema originale, ma è lo stato a energia più bassa che può essere creato usando qualsiasi sovrapposizione degli
stati recuperati nel nostro sottospazio. L'occupanza orbitale di questo stato produrrà un'energia minore o uguale a
quella dell'occupanza ottenuta dallo spazio recuperato. Quindi questa occupanza è una stima migliore della nostra
occupanza dello stato fondamentale. Possiamo ripetere il processo di configuration recovery usando questa nuova occupanza e possiamo iterare
finché i nostri criteri di convergenza sono soddisfatti. La diagonalizzazione quantistica basata su campioni è veloce rispetto ad
altri algoritmi near-term come VQE. È più scalabile ed è robusta al rumore e agli errori nel campionamento. Richiede però
ancora che prepariamo un buon ansatz con una grande proiezione sul supporto del vero stato fondamentale del nostro sistema. Se non si sa nulla del
nostro vero stato fondamentale, SQD potrebbe dover essere usato in combinazione con altri metodi per apprendere prima del
stato fondamentale e avvicinarsi iterativamente.
SQD svolge un ruolo critico nell'emergente suite di algoritmi ibridi classico-quantistici ed è uno dei
maggiori motori verso il quantum computing utile.